welcome to this video a new part in the
series about tactics and calculation
yeah this time we're going to look at
one particular position and one that
really requires some yeah some some good
calculation and imagination to really
find the solution the position arises
relatively early in a game so I'm going
to go through the moves it's about it's
a game between the minion Grandmaster
Gabrielle sarkeesian and now got number
two
Fabiano karana the game is from 2009 so
five years old back then karana was some
let me quickly calculate it 17 years old
still are already very strong but at the
time it was a pretty even matchup in
terms of rating yeah
Khurana played the Bangkok gambit
probably not an opening that he would
venture nowadays in the super top-level
events but back then this game was
played in the European club cap and
there you weren't fighting openings
quite often so we got a pretty normal
and line here in the Banco all this has
been seen a number of times
white has made this artificial castle
ink on the rook to e1 and he very often
will play a 45 if given the chance in
fact he does that now a very early
breakthrough in the center yeah this
kind of breakthrough some do happen
frequently and it's a question if the
term it leads to if it leads to much for
white it's certainly very early pressure
against the seven pawn but on the other
hand there are also some simplifications
going on and sometimes black gets play
on the diagonal yeah black plays rook p7
Queen e2 attacking this
Queen b6 damn if white now decides to
take on his seven like takes Queen takes
and rook e8 that's embarrassing Queen
has no squares so you cannot take his
seven he went a form yeah this is some a
dual-purpose move it gets a square on b5
sometimes you can jump there with a
knight but it also provides the apron
with some some some head start to to
make me promote later yeah black went
king of eight covering e7 Luke a3 and in
this position now Cara wanna played the
move 98 attacking the rook yeah the rook
now does not have many options it went
back to e3 we now reach the critical
position of this game piranhas now play
the move that turned out to be a mistake
you played the move Bishop to h6
certainly thinking about asking white
what are you going to do on this
diagonal yeah in fact in this position
right now has a very effective
continuation and I guess many of you
want to really treat this as a puzzle so
I just suggest that you pause the video
I'm not so good to get rid of the arrows
going to that you're going to pause the
video and look for yourself I'm going to
show you the solution in a couple of
seconds
this is one of those combinations that
comes a bit like a bolt from the blue
it's almost let's say heavy look both
from the blue because there are some
things that you can recognize that are a
little bit off about blacks position for
example the King on f8 that needs to
defend the e7 weakness the knight is not
super well placed on aid and the most
important thing is that Bishop h6 has
exposed this Bishop a bit this Bishop is
not protected however it is still very
surprising at least to me that white
already has an absolutely killing
combination available here the gishian
now played the amazing start on the
start of this amazing sequence with Luke
to e6 Congress if you have found the
general idea it's even better if you
have found the the point of it because
it's really a very very very deep move
yeah
the queen is attacked and the bishop is
attacked with check so the only critical
reply is to really take the rook white
captures on age six was check this was
clear how does it continue after Knight
g7 blocking this check White has the
strong reply Queen to e5 which will win
the knight with a killing attack it's
not just getting material back the
attack will be overwhelming yeah in the
game the black player went to g8 that's
the toughest defense and now comes the
amazing point of the whole sequence it's
very likely that many players will come
in their calculations to this point and
then they will probably look a bit
further maybe consider stuff like that
threatening made yeah when Knight f6 is
possible or they might consider Jam was
like yeah
Queen e5 but that's not threatening made
the night only aid is covering the whole
combination only works due to the fact
that white now has the next hammer blow
he can now play look b3 and this is just
absolutely beautiful it puts this weird
rook on a three-on-three and this really
means that both white rooks are said a
secre Feist yeah yeah like him after
this move resigned
yeah bird wine if black takes white
captain shiny six King edge 8 and now
Karenia 7 that's just brilliant Queen f8
is the mating thread based on the fact
that this Knight has such an unlucky
position yeah and of course Knight g7
checkmate we just take and made him
great so black cannot take the rook yeah
but what should he play yeah let's say
I'm you play Queen a6 and wipe the
straights and takes here why does a
piece up Queen a6 not possible and
there's really no good square if you go
here white will just take the rook and
he now is a piece up again and he has an
ongoing attack so a fantastic
combination here by soggy C on which I
really think it's not easy to spot
simply because um might not expect such
a decisive turn of events while blacks
position might look slightly awkward you
probably don't believe you can punish it
so severely
but Luke e6 is really a fantastic way to
review blacks play and takes bishop
takes and after king f7 by the way
there's also Queen b3
here after Queen takes b3 checkmate we
have an immediate mate so a great
combination here played by one of
armenia's top players
Gabrielle sagessa nowadays also they're
known as a second to Levon Aronian by
the way alright I hope you enjoyed this
great combination and maybe you found
the solution if you did with everything
look b3 then very much congrats to you
very very difficult to find thanks for
watching